>>Kristin: I will load
up three or four problems
and I'll have them in pairs.
I'll hand them the one iPad.
It is possible to actually
use one iPad and get this done
in a class, 'cause
that's all I have.
And I'll say, "All right,
you teach him how
to do this problem."
And you can get help
from the person next
to you if you need it.
It's okay, it's a team process.
>>Student: MD is
twenty-one and D equals RD.
>>Kristin: When they're
finished, I save it
and then I'll pull up a
problem very similar to it,
and I'll hand it
to their partner.
And say, "Okay, now it's your
turn, you do the same thing."
>>Okay, this is a question.
Make sure you read the
question carefully.
>>Student: Thank you.
>>Kristin: Okay.
>>And they hand it back to
me, I make sure it's all saved
and then I move on
to another pair.